[Music]
you have got to meet the 105 year old
lady from louisiana who ran a hundred
meters and set a world record we went to
meet miss julia hawkins and expected
she'd be real excited to talk about the
race but she told us it's just a drop in
the bucket when it comes to the race of
life
and she's off at
105 years old in a class all by herself
and with a fresh-picked flower in her
hair
julia hawkins was running for the record
books at the louisiana senior olympic
games
[Applause]
she is running 100 meters a little bit
more than a football field and has to
stay in that lane despite not being able
to see much more than about a foot in
front of her because of her age
miss hawkins stays in race shape mostly
by jogging a mile or two a day
near her baton rouge home that she and
her husband built together back in 1948
and that's where we first met her the
day before the race well hello miss
julia hello nice to meet you i'm david
well david we've been waiting a long
time on you well
have you ever wanted to be a world
record holder not particularly no are
you impressed by it no not particularly
i'd do many other wonderful things
before this this is just a drop in the
bucket
she grew up in the 1920s when a train
ticket cost about a nickel what was the
state of the world when you were born
much calmer
fewer buttons
and no but lots of books to read
she became a teacher and fell in love
with gardening
she shared that love for nature with a
fellow student at lsu named murray free
hawkins jr or buddy as they called him i
met him the first day at lsu i went home
and wrote about him in my diary he was
so smart it was so clever and so fun he
had a good sense of humor and he was
vivacious and wonderful we were married
by telephone
by telephone at that time murray was at
pearl harbor serving in world war ii
together they raised four children and
after 70 years of marriage murray died
at the age of 95.
did you want to live to be this old
i couldn't imagine being this old
without him it's not the same
it's not quite as wonderful
what are your dreams
i don't have a dream
i just want to go to sleep and let it
end
that's what my husband did
we were sleeping together and he sang
love songs to me that night
wonderful songs
so that's a wonderful way to go
well until that happens
we
are going to cheer you on
thank you
which takes us right back to that 100
meter run
on race day among those cheering her on
were two of her former students 90 year
old rosemary and evelyn who's 89.
she finished in just under one minute
three seconds setting a world record as
the oldest american and the first woman
to run 100 meters in her age group
i'm so happy
now you know every winner deserves a
press conference and this one set her
own rules okay one question a piece
you want to do it again
yeah
right now
no how about it 106. do it again
maybe so
who knows
see how i feel when i get up in the
morning
oh love everything about miss julia
david she started racing at 101
wow cause why not cause why not
dave you sure know how to pull on those
heartstrings man great job y'all i fell
in love but i didn't i did too right now
walked in 10 minutes later i was gonna
say we've been waiting a long time
i love that she called you out
her when i grow up i love everything
about her
her mind is there her body is there so
sharp lives by herself she does alone
and a mile or two every day what y'all
did yesterday a mile or two
thank you david thank you miss julia